hong kong's usually bustling victoria
park behind barricades and police for
years it's been the scene of candlelit
vigils to remember those killed in the
1989 tiananmen square massacre
but this year it was blocked off shadows
of clouds on the empathy park
illustrating what activists say is an
increasingly dark chapter in the
territory's history
freedom is starting to decline the
freedom in hong kong including freedom
of expression freedom of action all of
them are weakened everyone is remaining
silent because they are terrified of
getting arrested
dozens of police were deployed to
streets around the park and the busy
retail district of causeway bay
i just came here and there are so many
police i found it a bit troublesome
police had warned the public not to
gather in groups to mark the 33rd
anniversary passes by were stopped or
questioned their bags checked even this
man who was carrying a toy tank he said
had bought at the shops before three
years ago we had the free
to memorize this mascara for the
tinderman square
but just three years
everything changed
this is very dangerous just brick and
some practice
this is the third year all public
commemorations of the event have been
banned covert was the explanation last
year and the year before
2019 tens of thousands gathered around
the statue of the goddess of democracy
she was built as a copy of this erected
in tiananmen square by pro-democracy
protesters in 1989.
that was months before a military
crackdown killed what rights groups say
may have been thousands of peaceful
demonstrators chinese officials say 300
died
the footage of a lone protester standing
in front of a line of tanks became one
of the most powerful symbols of the late
20th century
but since beijing implemented a
controversial security law in 2020 the
annual commemorations have become
smaller this year for the first time
none was planned
many protest leaders are in jail or in
exile and the goddess of democracy
statue has been taken away
i'm disappointed because although no
one's organized any commemorative event
the authorities are already on high
alert
but candles did burn in the windows of
the u.s consulate the white house
accusing authorities in hong kong and
china of trying to suppress memories of
the massacre those sentiments echoed in
taiwan china views as a breakaway
republic there a copy of another famous
hong kong statue was on show to
commemorate the victims of tiananmen a
sign that despite china's efforts their
descent will not be silenced alex
o'brien al jazeera